والان نعود لملف الصين وتايوان حيث نحاول
استدعاء الخلفيه التاريخيه للنزاع المستمر
منذ اكثر من سبعه عقود تايوان هي ارخبيل
من الجزر جنوب شرقي اسيا يفصلها مضيق عن
البر الصينيه على بعد نحو 140 كيلومترا
بدات القصه عام
1949 عندما فرت اليها الحكومه الوطنيه اثر
انتصار الشيوعيين في الحرب الاهليه
وسيطرتهم على بر الصين الرئيسي
منذ خمسينيات القرن الماضي كانت الصين
كدوله اي انها تجلس في المقعد الدائم في
مجلس الامن وفيها السفارات الخاصه بالدول
الاخرى هذا الوضع انتهى مع بدايه
السبعينيات القرن الماضي عندما قرر الرئيس
الامريكي ريتشارد نيكسون زياره الصين
لاسبوع هذا الاسبوع عرف لاحقا بالاسبوع
الذي غير العالم في النهايه ادت الاتصالات
وزيارات الى التطبيع العلاقات لكن ليس في
عهد نيكسون انما في عهد الرئيس جيمي
طبعا تطور العلاقات
اسس على تفاهمات بين الطرفين اهمها سياسه
الصين الواحده اي اعتراف امريكي صريح
بوحده الصين
ومنح بيجين المقعد الدائم في مجلس الامن
في الامم المتحده وذلك مقابل الالتزام
بالجن بعدم اجتياح تايوان عسكريا
واشنطن اكدت على حمايه تايوان ووضعها تحت
مظلتها النوويه